how's it feel to be here among the crowd
among all the Vikings fans it's always
incredible fans are amazing here
honestly I'm more shocked to see that
photo that you just showed me of us
meeting when I was probably 15 years old
doing race to Witch Mountain yeah this
is an old old photo so that's the last
time that I was probably ever taller
than you that's pretty probably right
yes we've been with Alexander since the
very beginning of his career and now the
26 year old actor is getting ready for
the mid-season return of Vikings this
fall I'm going to
when you look back on that how do you
see that you've grown as a performing as
an actor I think it's been just leaps
and bounds I was a kid when I came on
the show yeah you know and in mentally I
still am but you know I've grown
physically let's talk about Vikings
where we're at right we're going into
new territory right now you know you
guys are on the run Rollo has just
returned this is a huge deal especially
the fans that have been wondering about
that character is there gonna be some
sort of showdown between doing and Rollo
you'll definitely see some very weird
character dynamics between the two I
don't want to give too much away you're
definitely gonna see a showdown for sure
it might not be with who you expect or
it might be with exactly who you expect
but I will say that this season 5b for
me was the most creatively fulfilling to
shoot really I just had so much to do
with Bjorn and I mean the end of 5b is
pretty insane I agreed to give you
refuge here if you were willing to fight
with us against the armies of your
country
I'll talk a little bit about your love
life okay I mean we've seen some ups and
downs big emotions we'll Jordan finally
settle down they do find what might be
the love of his life at some point I
think he's you're gonna see beer and
really kind of go more into that
paternal role he's gonna take on a
leadership role in every single aspect
of his life it's a relief to come down
to comic-con and hang out with your cast
in a place that's not like freezing cold
and you're not being whipped by the
winds all the time it is it really is
and like some of my cast members I
haven't seen for a very long time
because they're dead on the show now but
I can't tell you who but but it's pretty
uh it's pretty amazing to get to see
them we're such a family and it's really
really great to get to link back up with
everyone now I'm your social engineer
and we see you posting a lot of you
playing guitar is that something that
you would love to do like to put out the
music to perform live an actor and the
grand scheme of thing is a great job
don't get me wrong but it is but it is a
job that you have to work at
consistently and there's a lot of
rejection that comes with the job and
you know sure you get lucky once in a
while but if you want to a career that
lasts it's like you have to work at it
and constantly and it would be naive of
me to think that the music industry
wouldn't be the same way so for me yeah
I love music you know it really has a
special place in my heart that's why I
like putting out the videos because I
think it's like it's fun to just share
with what you're doing but you know I'm
in no place right now to be able to like
commit my life to a whole new career
[Music]